[TEXT: I swear to God and before the Colombian
people, to defend Colombia’s laws and Constitution.]
On August 7th 2018, Iván Duque Márquez was
sworn in as president of Colombia.
His campaign promise was straightforward:
to get the country in shape and ready for
a rapid development process.
Enough time has passed since Iván Duque rose
to power for VISUALPOLITIK to ask some questions:
What is the true strategic plan of Duque’s
government?
That is, how does he want to transform Colombia?
Can he achieve this goal?
What could be the legacy of his passage through
Casa Nariño – the Colombian White House?
Listen up.
(INTRO)
With almost 50 million inhabitants, Colombia
is the second-most populous country in South
America.
But it is, above all, a very, very complicated
country:
On the one hand, there’s the problem of
the guerrillas and drug trafficking, which
happens to be one of the country’s biggest
industries.
To give you an idea, Colombia produces no
less than 70% of all the white powder on the
planet.
70%!
Of course, as you can imagine, behind this
huge business that moves thousands and billions
of dollars every year, there are some powerful
criminal organizations.
Organizations that are willing to control
their territory come hell or high water.
That’s precisely why violence rates remain
so high.
(AUDIO: Colombia: homicides increased in 2018
due to violence after the FARC’s disarmament-
According to the country's forensic authority,
there were 12,130 homicides last year, 6.7%
more than in 2017.
- DW)
And the violence isn’t limited to drug deals
gone bad or territorial disputes.
In the last three years alone, it’s estimated
that more than 500 community activists and
leaders lost their lives at the hands of these
groups; and about 200,000 people have been
displaced from their homes.
And it doesn't end there.
The ELN, a far leftist guerrilla group – also
linked to drug trafficking – continues to
operate;
(AUDIO: 21/01/2019 The ELN guerrilla claims
the attack on the police academy that caused
more than 20 deaths.
RTVE)
What’s more, about 3,000 former members
of FARC may have taken up their weapons again;
and Coca plantations are at a record high.
(AUDIO: Coca crops in Colombia reached an
all-time high in 2017 with 171,000 hectares.
UN News)
As if all these problems weren’t enough,
Colombia has recently had to deal with the
arrival of hundreds of thousands of Venezuelans
fleeing Nicolás Maduro’s despotic regime.
It’s estimated that approximately 1.5 million
Venezuelans already live in Colombia.
One thing that is very positive is the Colombian
solidarity that’s been witnessed.
The problem is that this influx of people
also puts enormous pressure on stability and
public resources.
Ok, so let's say this is the downside.
But it’s not all bad news in Colombia.
You see, despite all the continuing problems,
such as drug trafficking, guerrillas, paramilitary
groups, violence, corruption... the country
has actually registered an average economic
growth of 3.8% per year over the last 40 years;
The middle class has grown and the country
hasn’t suffered any hyperinflation.
And, don’t think this is normal because
it’s anything but.
Don’t forget that we’re talking about
South America.
In that same period, Peru, Bolivia, Argentina,
Ecuador, Brazil and Venezuela have undergone
hyperinflation processes.
In other words, we could almost say that Colombia
is a model of stability.
However Colombian President Iván Duque doesn’t
quite agree.
(AUDIO: Colombian President Iván Duque affirms
that he isn’t satisfied with the more than
3% growth that the Colombian economy is expected
to have this year and intends to “push the
country to grow by more than 5% annually”.
ElPaís.com.co)
[TEXT: And of course, I’m not satisfied,
I’m not saying that we should grow by more
than 3% and that’d be enough, no!
We want more, and I state it like this: Colombia
is a country that has a per capita income
of almost $ 7,000.
We are an OECD country, the other OECD countries
have per capita incomes of more than $ 30,000,
so my question is, how long would it take
Colombia to reach that level of per capita
income?
100 years growing at 1% or 20 years growing
at above 5%.
What we need to do is get the country to grow
Make decisions to get that sustained growth
and that’s what we are doing.]
Yes, the Colombian president has set a goal
of 5%.
Now, will they be able to achieve it?
How will they go about it?
It seems complicated considering the scenario
described, doesn’t it?
Well, you know what?
We can’t say if he’ll be successful or
not, but the important thing is that this
government has a plan – which, unfortunately,
doesn’t seem to happen so often these days,
right President Macri?
And it’s a plan that doesn’t look too
bad, and which we can summarise into three
main points.
Listen up.
(FLEEING LATIN AMERICAN TAXATION)
This may come as a surprise, but in general,
Latin American countries’ tax systems have
one common characteristic:
They have the highest corporate taxes on the
planet.
Want an example?
Listen up.
The inability of the government to raise money
from living, flesh and blood people, has made
them tax the productive system voraciously.
This is quite the opposite of the example
set by Nordic countries, and they are often
held up as a benchmark.
And, if Latin America is usually a disaster
in this field, Colombia is the worst of the
worst.
But okay, some of you may be wondering, Simon,
how much worse?
1 point, 2 points?
Well, not even close.
To give you an idea, according to the latest
Doing Business report from the World Bank,
the effective tax rate on Colombian companies,
that is, if we consider all the taxes that
a company is obliged to pay: local, national,
labor, corporate…
Then it turns out that Colombian companies
face an average rate of a whopping 71.9%.
71.9% of the company’s commercial profit,
that is the difference between income and
expenses without taking taxes into account,
goes directly into the Public Administration’s
pocket.
To give you an idea, when a Colombian company
buys a machine, VAT cannot be fully deducted
for that purchase.
And companies have to pay taxes even if they
are losing money.
Crazy, isn’t it?
And obviously, all this has consequences:
Such high taxes on the productive sector affect
the Colombian economy’s ability to be competitive.
And on top of this we have to add the exhausting
and tedious bureaucracy that is so typical
in Latin American countries.
Basically, under these conditions it would
be easier to win a fight against a professional
boxer like Andrew Cancio or Floyd Mayweather,
than it would be to start a business that
works.
Surely now you understand why Latin American
countries generally have low investment levels,
low export levels and a lot, a lot of informal
economies.
(AUDIO: 05/2017: Latin America’s informal
economy surpasses that of sub-Saharan Africa
for the first time.
World Economic Forum)
In fact, it’s estimated that more than 54%
of Colombian companies aren’t operating
within official guidelines.
And of course, an informal company can’t
access large contracts, bank financing or
have legal security.
They just can’t grow.
Well, addressing this situation is precisely
the first major point of Ivan Duque's plan.
In fact, at the end of last year he got the
Congress of the Republic of Colombia to approve
a comprehensive tax reform.
His tax reform.
Basically, the reform aims to reduce the tax
requirements of Colombian companies by slightly
increasing taxes on higher personal incomes,
for example to people who earn more than $120,000
and who currently pay low taxes.
The reform will also increase VAT collection.
So, with the new reform, corporate income
tax will be progressively reduced from 33
to 30%; some additional taxes will disappear
and a simplified single-tax system with very
low rates will be created to encourage the
formalization and growth of small businesses.
[TEXT: With a 100% discount of VAT paid on
capital goods and a 50% discount of the ICA
and the gradual dismantling of the presumptive
income.
In addition to a simple regime that differentiates
rates, especially for fledgling companies,
is having effects.]
And that's not all.
In addition, the reform has also created tax
incentives for entrepreneurs, for investments
in large projects, investments in the tourism
sector and in the so-called orange economy.
And yes, okay, this may seem controversial,
after all, why apply it to some sectors and
not others?
But at least it seems to be a step in the
right direction, doesn’t it?
The problem, and perhaps what has made this
project so controversial, is that Duque is
going to increase public spending significantly
and the government already has a high public
deficit.
So even though the measure means a reduction
of taxes in the medium term, the truth is
that in the short term it implies increasing
them.
That is, while the reductions are progressive
and will be applied gradually, the increases
will be applied from the very beginning.
For example, a temporary surcharge on bank
profits.
And this hasn’t been popular at all.
But still – and you know that on VisualPolitik
we don't like tax increases at all – we
think the change is a step in the right direction.
Latin America in general and Colombia, in
particular, have to treat the productive sectors
better.
Latin America needs more companies, not more
taxes.
Unfortunately, this reform has been declared
unconstitutional due to a formality.
Now the government has to get it approved
again in Congress.
Could President Duque get it through?
(THE ORANGE ECONOMY)
The second key point in Iván Duque's strategy
is to promote the so-called orange economy
with fiscal incentives, participatory loans,
venture capital and startup accelerators.
Now let’s pause a second.
Many of you, especially those who aren’t
Colombian, will be wondering, what on earth
is the orange economy?
Well, no, it has nothing to do with the fruit,
it’s an umbrella term for creative activities
that are related to intellectual property:
music, design, audiovisual productions, YouTube
channels, architecture, art, software design,
etcetera, etcetera.
[TEXT: Zero, zero income tax for 7 years to
all new ventures in the creative and technological
industries because these are the years where
those ventures take off.]
Look, have you noticed that more and more
movies and series are being filmed in Colombia?
Even more and more productions from platforms
such as Netflix or Amazon Prime are being
made in this country.
And there’s a good reason for this.
In 2012, Law 1556 was passed, which provides
significant tax breaks and aid to produce
and shoot films and TV series in Colombia.
That way, they not only sought to grow the
national film industry but also to foster
a better image of the country around the world.
This resulted in a soaring number of productions
shot in Colombia.
Well, now Iván Duque wants to do the same
with all the activities that make up this
“orange economy”.
And pay attention because this is serious
business.
Today Colombia’s orange economy is almost
three times larger than the coffee industry
and almost as big as the entire mining sector.
We’re talking about economic activities
whose worldwide trade grows at annual rates
of 7% and whose value in 2015 exceeded 500
billion dollars.
(AUDIO: “The orange economy is larger than
new oil.
Oil reserves are limited but creativity is
unlimited.
We have to know that the most important heritage
we have in a society is the talent of its
people.”
Ivan Duque)
Well, in order to boost other ‘orange economy’
activities, the government is implementing
participatory financing plans, venture capital
initiatives, entrepreneurship centers and
tax exemptions.
So, will it work?
Will the orange economy really be able to
transform Colombia?
Only time will tell, but, you know what?
This plan sounds pretty good.
And the plan is different in that it is linked
to human capital and not just natural resources
or large companies that have suspiciously
close ties to governments, which, unfortunately,
is the norm in Latin America.
But it doesn’t end there.
We still have a third essential pillar in
this strategy.
(THE NEW BETS)
It isn’t strictly ​​Iván Duque’s
idea, but it looks like the new government
has accepted it.
Colombia wants to become a big player in the
world market for medical cannabis.
This is a sector that is literally growing
like weeds and is expected to become a market
of almost 50 billion by 2025.
And Colombia intends to have a slice of that
pie, more than 40%.
We’re talking about a huge sector and a
considerable boost for the Colombian economy,
especially for the economy in the poorest
rural areas.
(AUDIO “It calls us to the possibility of
being very important worldwide players in
terms of exports, estimates state that we
could effectively reach levels of US $6 billion
annually in exports”.
Saúl Pineda, Vice Minister of Business Development)
Well, along with the pointy green weeds, the
government’s other big gamble consists of
promoting fracking to increase oil production.
So far four pilot projects have been approved
that could produce more than 400 thousand
barrels per day when fully operational.
This would mean increasing Colombia's oil
production by almost 50%.
In conclusion, with all these measures and
with greater investment in infrastructure
and education, Ivan Duque’s government plans
to achieve its objective of raising Colombia's
economic growth to above 5%.
Will they achieve it?
Here on VisualPolitik we’ll be watching
closely, but as things stand, it doesn’t
look too bad.
Of course, there are other issues yet to resolve
and which could generate several problems:
for example, the sharp increase in public
spending or the constant devaluation of the
Colombian peso.
And, of course, Duque’s government hasn’t
limited itself to act only in the economic
field.
What about drug-traffickers?
How can they improve security?
What are they doing in terms of foreign policy?
Well, we'll cover these topics in an upcoming
video here on this channel.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.